okay very good question and surprisingly
i would guess that if you surveyed New
Yorkers on the street only a small
fraction of them would actually know
where their water comes from they might
have some vague idea that comes from
somewhere upstate but in fact New York
City and Westchester County so 8 million
from the five boroughs of New York City
plus a million from Westchester County 9
million total get their daily drinking
water supply from a 2,000 square mile
area that mostly is in the Catskills
1,500 acres sorry 1,500 square miles of
that of that is in the Catskill
Mountains and then the other 500 square
miles is is throughout Putnam in
Westchester County the system is
basically based on capturing rainwater
from rainfall that is moved down the
mountainside and obviously gets
collected through the system of streams
and reservoirs some natural reservoirs
natural lakes and other man-made lakes
19 of them in total they capture that
water and then through a series of
aqueducts that were built starting in
the mid 19th century all the way to the
early part of the 20th century I'll make
their way through gravitation there's no
pumps involved at all this is in other
word basically from the source up in the
Catskills down to New York City there is
an elevation drop it is very very small
you know per foot per mile but it isn't
enough to keep the water moving through
gravitation down to the cities uh you
know buildings and internal pipes so
that's essentially where the water comes
from about ninety percent of the supply
the 1.5 billion gallons that come to new
york city every day comes from the
Catskill Delaware system essentially
which is basically the Catskill
watershed which is the one of the falls
east off of the Catskill Mountains and a
Delaware watershed which falls West off
the Catskill Mountains and eventually
would have made it its way down to the
Delaware River were not captured in
these upstate reservoirs so ninety
percent comes from that source it's a
very very clean source because of the
relatively minor amount of development
up in that region to ten percent roughly
the
comes from the east of Hudson system or
the the westchester and putnam system
actually is not quite as clean and it's
it's safe enough to drink but it's much
more has much more pressure on it and is
much more exposed to potential
contaminants because of the heavy
development has happened when in putnam
in westchester over the last you know 50
to 100 years just to back up a second
but New Yorkers may not know that
they're the source of their drinking
water is unfiltered its treated with a
little bit of chlorine to hit basic
pathogens is treated with a little bit
of fluoride for to promote or to avoid
tooth decay and beyond that it's not
filters one of the last remaining
unfiltered system so that's why it
tastes so delicious that it's so clean
the problem is you've got to then
protect the water at its source up in
the Catskills and in these two Hudson
unfortunately because of all the
development east of Hudson part of the
system the EPA decided New York you got
to build a filtration plant that's the
only way you can absolutely safeguard
that part of the water supply the
problem is of course is once you build
that filtration plant it takes pressure
off of New York City off of the of those
upstate communities who live in the
watershed to actually protect the water
at source and a filtration plant is not
bulletproof you can still have pathogens
get through a filtration plant and cause
outbreaks of disease
well Riverkeeper was part of an historic
agreement in 1997 called the watershed
agreement and it was an agreement
between new york city and the state of
New York and the upstate communities who
live again in these watershed areas
there's been a long-standing tension
between the upstate communities who feel
like New York is robbing their their
their their water and not only that but
because of the need to protect the area
is also restricting their opportunity
for economic growth mechanized
evelopment and then New York has had to
balance that net frustration and also
make sure that it repays those upstate
communities in some way so in order to
protect the source of our drinking water
and to make sure that we remained in
unfiltered supply our Laurel we continue
to enjoy an unfiltered supply we reach
this agreement between environmental
groups like Riverkeeper the state of New
York upstate communities New York City
and basically it set out a series of
requirements that New York had to follow
in order to protect that upstate source
but also to help promote some
sustainable economic growth up in that
region to provide jobs and you know
economic stimulus so among those things
are acquiring land you need buffer lands
especially around the streams and the
reservoirs itself so that pollution
erosion sediment etc salt from the route
from nearby roads doesn't run into the
reservoirs and of course end up in our
drinking water supply you also need to
especially the east of Hudson system you
need to upgrade sewage treatment plants
that are in some cases are 40 50 years
old they're starting to fail they're
starting to discharge untreated or
partially treated sewage into our water
system now again by the time that makes
its way down to New York City through
natural systems and microbes and so on
that is treated but nonetheless you
don't want to have that too much of that
so you've got to upgrade the sewage
treatment plants you've got to help
homeowners to upgrade their septic
systems where you don't have sewage
treatment etc so Riverkeeper plays the
role of being the watchdog making sure
that new york city and its environmental
agency the dep
Department of Environmental Protection
is doing all the things that they agreed
to do in that 1997 agreement
unfortunately their track record has
been very mixed and now it very much
depends on who the mayor of New York is
at the time when you had mayor Giuliani
this is something that he did not think
was a priority he did not put a
commissioner in the dep who thought it
was a priority either and there was a
lot of kind of shenanigans going on and
a lot of cutting of budgets and not
putting enforcement officers up in the
watershed to make sure that the source
for water is protected Mayor Bloomberg
has been much better but still it's an
old agency and they've got a certain
bureaucratic ways of doing things
they've got certain kind of agency
resistance that that makes it difficult
sometimes to get them to do what they
need to do but Riverkeeper plays a role
of being watchdog to make sure they do
is we're supposed to do now the other
threat especially to the ninety percent
that comes from the catskill system is
that development pressures in this in
the Catskills have quadrupled over the
last you know seven years particularly
since 911 there was a there was a
migration of some New Yorkers who left
New York City after 911 because of you
know the fear of terrorism and so on and
a lot of them ended up going up to the
Catskill regions which is only you know
a couple hours away to settle and with
those additional people suddenly
developers started to see dollar signs
and saw the Catskills as a potential
economic boom area it is it's a gorgeous
area you've got the advantage of
obviously having a little bit higher
unemployment up there so there is a real
hunger for jobs that which means that
the local municipalities are going to be
generally supportive of whatever kind of
development comes up there so there's
really an increasing amount of pressure
to develop that area and if we do that
and we don't do it right and suddenly
that ninety percent starts to get
contaminated in a way that it really
hasn't been to date then suddenly new
york city is looking at having to build
potentially a filtration plant for that
west of hudson part of the system that
ninety percent which would cost current
estimates are 10 to 12 billion dollars
and you're talking about an annual
operation maintenance costs of about
half a billion dollars per year so you
can imagine New Yorkers water rates will
go through the roof so it's not that's
not a scenario that we want
there was something that we looked into
very rigorously around you know I'm not
long after the 911 attacks it became an
obvious question if you're looking at
new york's new york city in particular
the New York region's infrastructure
what are the potential vulnerable points
well obviously the Indian Point nuclear
power plant is one of those the chemical
plants over New Jersey or another but
certainly our water supply supply is
vital I mean Manhattan and the
surrounding five boroughs would not
survive very long without a source of
water because most of them whatever I
mean almost all that actually does come
from from upstate so clearly that was
concerned we did some investigation
there's two couple conclusions we came
to which patisserie stuff all the DEP
did step up their enforcement presence
up in the watershed to make sure their
security up there near the aqueducts
near the Kensico reservoir where a lot
of the water comes through to make sure
that those areas were protected from
some kind of you know attempt to blow up
you know the day I'm or blow up yeah the
Kensico reservoir and so that was
somewhat assuring secondly in terms of
if if of terrorists was to dump some
kind of chemical agent or mercury or
something that's highly toxic they could
pollute the entire system and poison New
Yorkers by the time that that was done
word would get out the DP would know
about it and New Yorkers would of course
be warned not to drink any of the water
so in terms of actually being successful
in killing New Yorkers by contaminating
the water supply you know it takes 60 to
90 days if you drop a drop of water and
these in some of the Upstate reservoirs
for it to make its way through the
system down into your taps here in New
York City but nonetheless they could
contaminate the Upstate supply and
heavily disrupt New York City because if
we were obviously without water for some
time until we could treat or or deal
with the poisoning of our system then
certainly that would disrupt the city